I'm pretty happy with us let's just
revised because I'm yeah fractions is
funny a whole bunch of skill sorts of
stuff all together when you do fractions
so even those three questions here
that's all they kind of each get a
different skill so how do you go from a
improper fraction right to Mitch new
look at some let's just hope but it
sucks we had that put the step Ciara
dish how many times how many times are
17 / 3 like that because just like a
long division that we were doing before
ok and then how many how many times nice
17 you go into a free go into something
I if I times right cuz you go can we
count it right 3 6 9 12 15 and then you
can't go anymore yeah so we've got those
five and that's why we get it this from
okay and then you've got the two where's
that come from what's that about yeah ah
fantastic so we got up to 15 and that
was the fifth multiple but 15 leaves two
still stuck on that numerator so the two
just stay there right I would point out
and I'm really glad you guys have been
using this language right if we were to
write this instead as a division we
would say something like or we could
write it like this rate we could say 17
one moment three is five remained active
to let you see that and so all of the
same pieces go into this as go into this
it's like this is the one we call this
that number you end up with start with a
cube remember their question good so
keys where the question is how many
ended up with two as bromwich is the
remainder what's left over and three
years oh yeah interesting with it in
over here we call denominator over here
we call a bomb
what time it's my eyes up by a type of
dividing line which makes exact sense
because literally 17 / 317 third is 17 /
3 does that make sense so to be the same
thing here as to how do we go that
working at the 1405 with the one anyone
someone who hasn't said anything yet
yeah okay so we're looking at the
denominators first so I noticed that
five is a buddha-bar then free but hold
on a second let's just be careful for
now if the denominator is bigger like
here's a big denominator 100 is a big
denominator baby is this whole is this
number is it a bit other is a small
about also very small right in fact the
bigger the denominator gets the smaller
the whole number that's okay so usually
a big to know various suggests a small
number we need other piece of
information can some of us just where
else we are a breath oh I mean I make 14
it's like
so I add it to an office and then to and
fourth fifth bigger than two computers
okay so we've got another step yep we've
used the same period in pressure while
we do the conversion what are the nice
things about this lots of different ways
to go through this obsolete one of the
ways reasons I like it is because look
there's a tener and it to their I will
fare the same then you don't have to
worry about comparing them you just can
work out this part and this part right
I'm working draw a picture of this right
actually in which you just next to your
arm and your where you've done this can
you draw for me do a couple of
rectangles my pictures are always so
helpful do a couple of rectangles
imagine of each of them is one ok how
would we draw two thirds on this
rectangle if this whole rectangle is one
well if i divide that into three here my
thirds right so two birds will be like
this and i'm missing one piece and that
piece is that be ok how about
four-fifths how about you know could I
do yeah billion pieces ok how quakecon a
second how many pieces to our I actually
want five pieces don't know because it
comes from the denominator right if I
were doing this one oh gee I've been
every one two three four five six I
don't even know how many you divided too
damn many pieces yeah and you want one
of them so here i'm going to divide into
five pieces let's see
and how many of them I got them I laptop
yeah this is this is where the full
content okay so you can see I mean my
diagram is not fantastic but you can
already see it clearly this one might be
bigger I what it's missing that piece is
missing it's much smaller than the piece
missing of it okay and lastly can
someone suggest is there may be a lion I
could do before i get to an art are
there's someone read off a light of
working to me any suggestions yeah um
I'm so what I did I did four times two
um and then the one above the formatted
time to again okay so we look at this
faction here so let's think about it's
always really helpful we've got language
to describe what's going on aiden is
doing something to this fraction to make
it easier to play a lot with this
fraction what's he doing we have a name
for this right the fraction he says to
agree what's the relationship between
these two fractions right yeah true the
same reduction is just that one what it
is simplified super fun very good so
this is kind of a simplified version of
this we call them blimp fractions
they're the same size but I like this
one even though it's less simple why do
I like it what's what's nice about it
for me thanks just so we got a white
hands up for the primer I can someone
yeah kini fantastic we're see this
before right Commons and nobody is great
because these guys are talking the same
language two eights here 18 there and
that's where the 38 hang on me and
they're comfortable make sense